Suite a ma vidéo sur les aplis d'rencontres
Les gens de Tinder m'ont contacté
Ils ont du se dire : "Put**n ce mec représente vraiment l'essence même de la séduction !"
SUPER FAUX.
Non, en vrai ils m'ont contacté, pour me donner des conseils.
*HUM HUM*
Le truc bien vexant.
En gros, ils m'ont transmis une étude officielle qui montre par exemple
Quels sont les profils les plus likés, quel genre de photo accroche le plus, tout ça tout ça
Voici les 6 types de mecs qui draguent le plus sur Tinder.
L'insta model
Il poste que des photos de lui dans les endroits les plus cools du monde,
Et s'il a un produit dans la main, ça veut dire qu'il est sponso.
Le quetard
Lui, il a pas le temps. Il est là juste pour niq*er.
Ah non non, on va rien montrer par contre hein, sinon je vais encore me faire censurer par YouTube.
Le mauvais acteur.
Lui, il fait le mec décontracté alors qu'en fait il est pas trop à l'aise.
"Salut la miss, alors moi je m'appelle 34 ans et je vais sur mes Frédéric."
"Et toi ?"
Le pot de colle
Celui qui va insister pour te raccompagner même de jour et qui va tenter d'être galant en devenant étouffant.
"Ah tu vas aux toilettes ? Tu veux que je te tienne la porte ?
Ca me dérange pas hein, je peux le faire pendant plusieurs heures !"
"Peut-être que je devrais lui envoyer un 16e message..."
l'homme marié
Attention, ça grouille sur Tinder, les infidèles !
"Ecoute, toi et moi je trouve qu'on a vraiment accroché, j'ai envie de te demander en mariage direct !"
"Euh...
Ah tiens !
Veux-tu m'épouser ?
Non ? Attends, je t'ai mis un super like !"
Le frustré
Il connait mieux que toi ce qu'il te faut et ce qui est bien pour toi.
Macho et frustré de l'entrejambe, si tu lui mets un vent, il t'insulte direct.
"Ah je ne te plais pas ? Tu connais mal tes propres goûts en fait, c'est pour ça, c'est... c'est ridicule !"
*rire chelou*
Et maintenant, les 6 types de femmes qui draguent le plus sur Tinder.
"la femme trop Busy"
Ce qui casse complètement le charme de la rencontre
"Mais bien sur qu'on peut se voir ça me ferais super plaisir.."
"Alors j'ai un créneau de 10 minutes dans 4 mois si tu veux, on peut se fumer une clope mais pas une 100s hein.. j'ai pas le temps"
"La grosse lâche"
Elle, elle n'a aucun courage. Elle a l'air partante mais elle te pose lapin sur lapin.
Tu la verras JAMAIS.
- Allô, Chloé ? - Allô, ouais. - Tu te rappelles de notre rendez-vous.
Ouais, ouais, je suis trop chaude !
- Ouais mais t'y es pas donc euh ...
-Non mais t'inquiète y'a aucun problème.
- Ouais mais comme t'y es pas y'a quand même un petit problème enfin euh...
L'arnaqueuse
Elle, elle est là parce qu'elle vient d'arriver en ville
Elle veut juste se faire des ami(e)s
Et accessoirement trouver un appartement et un travail.
Et toi alors
qu'est ce que tu cherches comme type de relation?
-Oh un petit 20m² dans le 11ème ça m'irait
-Attends mais qu'est ce que tu fais là?
Celle qui vient de rompre et qui ne s'en est pas encore remise
Elle a jamais dragué en ligne, et elle va essayer de retrouver son ex dans tous ce que tu fais.
-C'est marrant quand tu souris tu me fais penser à mon ex
ça te dérangerait pas de porter ce masque de lui?
qu'est ce que t'es beau!
-Celle qui n'a rien à dire
Un blanc entre chacune de tes phrases elle répond par monosyllabes
et pourtant elle a passé un super moment avec toi
l'ultra narcissique
Elle, elle est là pour parler d'elle, rien que d'elle et sa vie inintéressante
Elle parle pas à quelqu'un
elle parle à elle-même
"Et c'est là que je me suis rendue compte qu'en fait mon frère
c'était un peu comme mon meilleur ami quoi
Très bien, c'est la fin de la séance
on verra la semaine prochaine tout ce qu'est le rapport au père
En tout cas très bon rendez-vous Tinder
c'est c'était un vrai plaisir, un régal
On se retrouve sur TF1 pour la météo avec en guest spécial Delahousse
Alors apparemment, porter un chapeau sur ta photo de profil, diminue tes chances d'être liké de 12%
Sourire, augmente tes chances d'être liké de 14%
Bon après tout dépend de ton sourire, hein !
Porter des lunettes diminue tes chances d'être liké de 15%
ça se fait pas
Après c'est vrai que si tu es très très moche, plus les lunettes sont grandes, plus elles cachent ton visage
Hein donc ça peut-être aussi un plus.
Si tu mets des photos de face, tu peux être liké de plus de 20%
Alors ça peut vous paraître bête,
Mais je vous jure sur Tinder, il y a des gens qui font des trucs
vraiment très très stupides.
Comme par exemple : Les photos à plusieurs !
On ne sait pas lequel t'es ! Surtout que la meuf peut préférer un de tes potes !
Les mêmes d'Internet, Heu frère, on n'est pas sur 9gag !
Ou encore les photos prises de hyper loin. Et bien c'est simple, on ne te voit pas !
Si le paysage prend 15 fois plus de place que toi sur la photo,
c'est qu'il faut pas la mettre. ça donnera jamais envie de te rencontrer.
Par contre ça peut donner envie de visiter le Vaucluse
Ou encore ceux qui mettent des photos en couples. LOL
On se demande ce qu'il fout sur Tinder en fait.
Alors, mettre une photo de ta teub, diminue tes chances d'être liké de 100%
Bon okay, ce chiffre je l'ai inventé
Mais je pense qu'il est vrai quand même. Parce qu'une fois j'avais essayé...
Et enfin être très très beau, augmenterait tes chances de 100% de ne pas avoir besoin de Tinder
Ces gens là leur vie elle doit être trop facile hein
Hé excuse moi ! Bah regarde !
*Hurlement* Voix off:Ah mais il est trop beau ! Le BG quoi !
MATCH !
Les super likes matchent plus souvent que les likes normaux.
Et coûtent également plus chers.
ça va toi ?
Vos messages ont plus de chances de recevoir une réponse lorsqu'ils sont doublés, ou triplés.
Par contre, à partir de 110 messages, je pense que vous commencez à devenir lourd hein...
Là il faut arrêter
Réponds stp, vas-y wesh tu fais quoi ? Tu aimes l'origami ?
Maintenant les prénoms les plus likés sur Tinder, en France.
Et juste pour le kif, je vous montre les prénoms les plus likés sur Tinder en Corée.
Apparemment il y a pas mal de touristes en Corée en ce moment.
Un tiers des profils Tinder sont à la recherche d'autres choses que de l'amour ou du sexe
Comme par exemple de simple rencontre amicale
Sondage bien sûr réalisé sur des hommes et des femmes menteurs.
Je plaisante ! Evidemment sur Tinder tu es libre !
Tu rencontres les gens pour absolument ce que tu veux!
C'est toi qui décides, tout est possible !
-Tinder ça m'a servi à rencontrer mon coloc'
Mon groupe aussi
Mon collègue aussi
Et globalement tous mes potes, hein, donc Tinder c'est vraiment ça quoi !
Et votre femme aussi du coup, j'imagine?
Ah on peut aussi heu... Rencontrer des femmes ?
Je pense pas, vous vous trompez.
One, two, three, four !
-Le pic d'utilisation de Tinder, c'est le dimanche, à partir de 17 heures.
Pic, qui selon moi correspond pile poil aux gens qui n'ont pas réussi à pécho la veille hein le samedi soir.
Bon je dis ça je dis rien...
*Voix grave bizarre* OUI OUI OUI OUI OUI
Une relation sur 5, commence via une application de dating online
Dating online, qui, en France, utilise ce mot ?
Personne ? On est d'accord
Les chiens sont sur 10% des photos de profil.
*Aboiement*
Maintenant les métiers les plus likés sur Tinder en France
Troisième : Ergothérapeute.
Alors je sais pas s'il y a beaucoup d'ergothérapeutes en France...
Mais apparemment ils sont tous sur Tinder.
Les musiques les plus populaires sur Tinder.
Bon, on s'en doutait, le commercial ça marche toujours.
Evitez; je pense, les compos personnelles.
"J'aime faire souffrir les femmes en les manipulant"
Bref, si on rassemble toutes les infos, on est capable de dire quels sont, selon les stats Tinder, les meilleurs et les pires profils côtés filles et côtés garçons.
Let's go !
La pire meuf
Elle ne sourit pas, elle porte un chapeau et des lunettes, de toute façon ça on le voit même pas puisque la photo est de loin
Avec ses amis au premier plan.
La meuf parfaite
Elle s'appelle Alysée
Elle sourit de face sur la photo
Se connecte souvent le dimanche à 17 heures
Et envoie plusieurs messages d'un coup
Elle est guide touristique, ou éventuellement, ergothérapeute.
ça veut dire quoi ergothérapeute ?
Le pire mec
Sa première photo est une photo d'Internet pas drôle
Sa chanson est une compo nulle, il envoie beaucoup trop de messages avec bien sûr des fautes
et sur sa seconde photo, il est... de dos
Le mec parfait.
Il s'appelle Thomas, il est chef cuisinier
Il sourit
n'envoie que des super-likes, et peut éventuellement avoir un chien sur sa photo de profil.
Et si par hasard cet homme, en plus du chien s'avère être Ryan Gosling, c'est un petit plus non négligeable.
Bon ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que tout ça c'est évidemment que des chiffres.
Faut pas trop tout calculer non plus
Chacun a sa propre singularité, son propre style.
Et que ce soit sur Tinder, ou dans la vraie vie, ce n'est pas parce que tu ne t'appelles pas Thomas que tu ne peux pas trouver l'amour de ta vie, hein...
On est d'accord
Sachez que tous les goûts sont dans la nature, y compris le goût paprika.
Moi en tout cas je vous kiffe tous, je vous super like tous
Et si vous de votre côté vous avez apprécié la vidéo, swipez moi vers le haut en mettant des pouces en l'air.
Pour l'amour du love !
Pensez à vous abonner à ma chaîne Youtube, on y pense pas assez souvent, pourtant, un abonnement sur ma chaîne Youtube créé
Un abonnement dans le monde, sur ma chaîne Youtube
C'est quand même assez pratique et utile pour l'environnement donc n'oubliez pas, ça me fait plaisir et puis en plus heu... C'est gratuit.